alright let me set this up here okay so
I'm in the stairwell of my apartment
building right now to show you what the
reverb of a space like this does to a
human voice you can hear the reflections
of my words bounce around the walls in
here and mingle together to create this
complex echo that conveys information
about the space island the only thing
though is that I'm not in a stairwell
I'm in my office where I normally record
these voiceovers sitting pretty close to
the microphone in digital editing all
you need to do to add reverb to an audio
file is drag and drop
there are countless presets for
different spaces a couple of clicks and
you're good to go
take for example I don't know a school
dance in a gymnasium just add some crowd
sound effects and some band music apply
the appropriate reverb and voila
[Music]
digital software makes a lot of things
easier unfortunately the film you're
looking at right now George Lucas's
American Graffiti was made way before
these tools were invented so how do you
capture the acoustic spirit of a place
without the software to simulate it well
you could record the band playing in the
gym itself as you're shooting but that's
going to make thinking that all ended
make shots all SuperDrive you could
filter the tracks to muffle it a bit and
add some echo as it had been done up to
that point but that's just not going to
have the realistic quality you're
looking for you're gonna have two world
eyes it I love echo any kind of
reverberation or atmosphere around a
voice or a sound effect which tells you
something about the space that you're in
that's Walter Murch legendary film and
sound editor who has worked on some of
the best movies of all time including
American Graffiti and the Godfather what
you're watching now in the early 70s
Murch invented a technique called world
izing that solved the problem of
realistic reverb and you can hear it in
this scene
when the orchestra that is at the
wedding is playing the music it's being
broadcast to the set through speakers
and it has this wonderful sound the way
weddings really sound I then got hold of
the actual original according to that
music and did a kind of blending the
captured playback sound with the actual
sound it's an ingenious solution to the
problem Murch records the recording in
the space it's actually meant to be
playing capturing the exact acoustic
qualities of that location then he sinks
the original recording with that to
create this Frankenstein's monster that
has both the full body of the original
music and the signature of that outdoor
area that's world izing and in addition
to the naturalism it creates this
technique gives the sound editor amazing
control over something like a sonic
depth of field by adjusting the levels
on the sync tracks you can essentially
bring the sound backward or forward in
the mix when people are dancing and the
camera is up close you want to feel the
music so the editor can favor the clean
recording but when you have dialogue on
the other hand you can fade in more of
the world eyes recording which softens
the edges on the audio and allows speech
to punch through clearly without you
having to bring down the music volume
drastically low
mirch devised this process on George
Lucas's first feature film thx 1138 a
masterpiece of impressionistic sound
design he had to find a way to make
Lucas's futuristic underworld sound like
well a futuristic underworld like all
good inventions world izing emerged from
necessity and experimentation
The Godfather was the beneficiary of
what Murch came up with on thx so was
American Graffiti which leaned heavily
on world izing to place its extensive
radio soundtrack in the cars and on the
streets and in the school gymnasium in
Apocalypse Now many of the sounds coming
from megaphones loudspeakers and
helicopter radios our world eyes in all
these cases the result is an
extraordinary match between picture and
sound and the result of that is a deeper
immersion in the story you know I love
this about the craft of movies how a
problem that needs to be solved can
result in a technique that influences
the sound and feel of the whole medium
that's still true I think even now so go
out and create some problems surprise
yourself who knows maybe you'll change
film history hey everybody welcome to
20/20 thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace if you don't know you can
use Squarespace to make really beautiful
websites for anything you might need a
personal site a wedding website a site
for your business or portfolio and in
just a few clicks you can have that
website up and running their design team
has crafted templates that work on
computer browsers and on mobile
switching perfectly between the two you
can integrate your own photos and videos
with just a few clicks and you can even
link your social accounts so you can
Auto post to Twitter and Facebook all
from within Squarespace head over to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm / nerdwriter
for 10% off your first purchase thanks
guys I'll see you next time